if you've been wanting to play more  quent  you'll get your chance on ps4 very soon  I'm Tony and this is your card based  game spot news update The Witcher 3  smash hit card game is becoming a  standalone title and ps4 players can  jump into the technical test this  weekend the test runs from 10:00 a.m.  Pacific on Friday March 31st through  11:00 a.m. Pacific on Sunday April 2nd  you can build your own deck complete the  tutorial then get right to dueling other  Gwent enthusiasts developer CD Projekt  RED says this event is meant to test its  servers not to balance the game further  so it should be a fun weekend and to  keep up with all the Gwent news as we  near the full release be sure to  subscribe  on that note Gwent has no solid release  date right now but it is being planned  for ps4 Xbox one and PC and speaking of  big upcoming games why not check out our  lobby discussion about what we want from  destiny too  [Music]  you